[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever
we want all right so quarantine is kind
of like
unofficially over now right is it is it
everyone's got a lady
like memorial day week you're about to
get canceled oh [ __ ] i mean i'm here
hence where you are true because a lot
of things are opening back up a lot of
people are getting braver
and they're going back into the world
obviously with like you know
masks you gotta do [ __ ] and i've been
avoiding you guys for like
for the quarantine but that wasn't even
because of the point
just because bart stinks a shower
i heard germany's like going back to
normal like that they never even
experienced it or whatever yeah not
never because i do know a german
uh guy who said his friend or
acquaintance friend died from oh
my acquaintance friend he died oh i feel
like german just likes to forget things
even happened
oh true
but yeah like like now that it's kind of
like ending
and like now we have our like regular
days to get uh lives to get back to
i kind of regret not being more
productive during you are productive
i i wish i was more like like me and
nadeem had like the whole
you know challenge of like finishing it
would have been the perfect time to do
it exactly wait wait
you guys didn't keep up with it no no
why didn't it so we had a deal
okay we gave ourselves three months
right to write a movie
and if we couldn't finish in three
months that we would do a thousand
burpees which is impossible in one day
it's not impossible you break it down
dude i would [ __ ] work out we're
supposed to be so strict that we're like
okay we have to finish something yeah
it's so scary that we should just
[ __ ] finish the script you know i
think the problem
was what's the problem it's too long so
if it's three months
you're like oh wait till later but if
you're like exactly what i did
48 hours on monday we're gonna revisit
it
then you're already just gonna block out
that weekend you're like i'm not gonna
do [ __ ] we should we should do like
something really quick or four weeks
later that's already too long forty
eight hours
two hours because if it's three months
i'm gonna wait till the last week yeah
same thing with three weeks it needs to
be two or three days yeah buy next jk
news well i can't edit your videos i
can't
wait two weeks two weeks that's in the
middle right because bart's thing is 24
hours
your guys think was three months right
by next jk news
you guys all three you finish a script
or whatever all right just at least the
rough draft
true like they got to finish it yeah
because we're dragging tim in this too
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm setting it
up in your brain like you got a tree
like it's an emergency right so like for
example like let's say
god forbid one of our parents gets hurt
goes to the hospital
you're not gonna be like but what about
bart and jill's vlog videos
i can't [ __ ] do this [ __ ] right now
too bad i gotta go save my mom and my
dad i think of barton george it's gotta
be like that it's gotta be like that
[ __ ] it this weekend i'm doing it and
then that's what and that's my point
though
quarantine was it was the perfect time
to read we were still
we're still in it dude i feel the
opposite i feel like i was too
productive during quarantine i wish i
would have taken a break because now
everybody's got a vacation now
they're all going to want to hang out i
have too many friends
you wrote too many people all bothering
me huh you wrote too many books
i wrote too many books i did i produced
that's good now you now you have the
time to hang out now
now you deserve it yeah now you're doing
this i'm gonna quarantine myself now
eminem's gonna see this and then be like
damn i'm proud of her
you guys are gonna hang out i'm too busy
you only got one shot
do not miss your chance to blow
opportunity knocks once in a lifetime
yo eddie yo
did you know that inside jokes okay this
month
is the 20th anniversary of the
marshmallows lp
oh i know it's between he's his biggest
fan
okay shut the [ __ ] up crazy though like
kids [ __ ] still love eminem like no
[ __ ]
they like to talk [ __ ] though really i'm
like you don't even know you don't even
know where stan
came from you say you stand in all these
celebrities you don't even [ __ ] know
yeah you wouldn't even be able to say
that
i mean there's definitely a whole like
uh audience of people who are like
who even listens to him and yeah bumps
eminem you know but i think
young white girls in the midwest i mean
they love it and nikki or yeah
or nikki old halfway girls yeah marshall
matters lp will forever be
like classic yeah it's my second
favorite album
what's your first yes yeah are you an
eminem soul girl yes which comes to me
so next year will be the next year will
be the 25th anniversary of the nem show
or maybe it's in two years singles
aren't each one yeah i don't know i
don't i don't know
and then uh eminem shows without me um
oh i like that okay yeah i like that one
eminem show and [ __ ]
the one for his mom yeah cleaning out
the closet or no oh yeah no longer
curtain call every time i want to leave
every time i want to leave yeah martial
math is lp that's mushroom that's my
favorite song from that one yeah
yeah that's my [ __ ] too i'm more of a
detail
what's your favorite song bart sing it
that was four the d is
so 12. i love that song
what he said he was a d12 fan i was like
quote your favorite song he's like the d
is so 12.
yeah i feel like they were the original
like lonely island
like his music videos and stuff he was a
troll or like a troll like it was the
first troll
bazaar's sense of humor is very bizarre
bizarre was never really uh
you don't listen to a bizarre song for
like oh man bars yeah
just for like weird [ __ ] he's just weird
yeah he's like i [ __ ] my dog got a
pregnant
and you're like that's not even a rhyme
yeah and it literally wouldn't even rise
[Laughter]
i got d12 mixed up with g unit man i
don't have one
they're so different because i was like
wait aren't wasn't the game from d12 and
i'm like wait a minute
no it was around the same time that
well because m discovered uh 50. so
that's why i was kind of i
remember that yeah because dre came out
discovered m
or yeah and then 50 came out so i was
like
i connected 50 with d12 because eminem
created
you know that's his crew i mean yeah
yeah
but i went into quarantine being like
i am gonna [ __ ] get so much done and
then the fact that
we just have so much time and nothing's
really like there's
no urgency there's no sense of urgency
i'm like i have
no um i just i don't i'm not motivated
at all to do creativity
can i jerk my dick real quick and make
y'all look make y'all look really stupid
please
do i i ended up starting a new business
it's a it's i'm not even releasing it
and telling people
but it's a live call situation where i
do one-on-ones with fans and [ __ ] and
everyone there's an audience there
and subscription thing and then i
literally get people
to get promotions upgrade their life
because you know my life has always been
have fun while improving and [ __ ] and i
really been sharing this message but now
i'm like effectively doing it because
i'm really passionate about
you know upgrading our fans lives and
[ __ ] right mm-hmm hi
another thing is i'm gonna be debt-free
next year
that's right that's like a hundred grand
baby hundred grand
that's beautiful people like yo i
thought you had money yes but i have an
addiction to investing
there's a lot of [ __ ] money that went
away and i'm not seeing the rewards for
because i love to invest and just the
other day i told myself i'm not gonna do
this i just bought five thousand dollars
of more cryptocurrency
and that's a ton bad now yeah that's
what i'm hearing but i'm not i'm not
feeling bad all i'm saying is like i
told myself i'm a dollar cost average
which means every day you buy a little
bit in an overtime you know you
accumulate and you average it out
and and i say i'm going to do maybe
let's say 100 a day right
and then here i go 5 000 in one day and
the next day three more thousand before
you know it it's 20 thousand dollars and
i'm just like this is the reason why
it feels like vegas i'm not broke i just
i'm addicted to investing in very risky
things
yeah yes i feel so stupid now
for what well he said he was going to
drink his dick and make me feel stupid
and i was like
all right yeah because you don't have
this problem because me and you both
i think we agreed that we we were super
focused and more
motivated we had the same
yeah we sometimes we take our parts out
and we measure it
yeah depending on how how hard he is
sometimes i beat him oh no yeah
no i feel great because i think um i
don't know if you
agree nikki but what ended up happening
was in real life pre-quarantined
i feel like i'm reacting and my scatter
brain
can't focus because i'm like dealing
with this business and that business i'm
just going back and forth and back and
forth right
but when i'm forced to physically stay
in one place and i can't get into
meetings with other people
and i'm just in the room or in the house
i get to do this
uninterrupted work so my brain
completes things instead of like in the
middle of it
oh [ __ ] i gotta go to that meeting let
me come back to this and then i totally
don't finish
that script or whatever you know i was
working on and then do you feel like it
kind of narrowed it down for you because
like my problem was before quarantine i
was like
okay i gotta keep on top of my schedule
i'm doing two podcast two channels dude
like i'm cast member over here
and then on top of that i had goals
where i was like but i also want a tour
but i also want to write a book but i
also want to do my stand-up but i also
want to it's like
all these things out here then because
the quarantine like there are no
stand-up shows there are no tours there
are no this
so i'm like okay and narrow down all
your goals narrow down to just
this yep and i felt yeah i felt more
productive and i felt like i had more
creative time
that's true but now i'm like i didn't
get to chill
[ __ ] chill man i've been i've been
chilling catching up on netflix shows
and [ __ ] snuggling with my wife i
started cooking i used to
never cook i like cooking yeah we i cook
[ __ ] now i played animal crossing but
even that started to feel like a job
they're like i gotta catch this amount
of fish today i gotta pay loan debt
yeah i gotta sell my turnips because i
invested you should just throw it away
just try two it's done now because i i
feel like i did my video and like i got
it all out of my system oh so you
haven't picked it up
i've been picked up in like five days oh
good for you i have crossed you're gonna
relapse soon you just gotta you gotta
relapse anniversary comes out in like
nine years dude nice so now since you've
heard my
inspiring story of what i've got
completed do you guys
feel beneath me and now you need to
catch up and that
that now it's time for you guys to be as
productive as
as me and nikki and and you have to do
something about it fine let's write
these
[ __ ] movie scripts and invest in
crypto i think you should we gotta be
more risky how about how about vegas
should we go to vegas
i want to go that's pretty productive
right that's as saying is let's go to
china and have someone cough on us i
don't want to be that risky
it's also closed yeah we're going to go
to vegas
in a week i'm down i'm getting into
bullying he's going to open up in a week
yeah joe and i get to bully you guys if
you don't make it
we were like oh you can't even write a
script damn
chill you know what my husband writes
scripts all the time
he actually did and sells them sells
them he sold them he stole them
you know what you guys [ __ ] up too
with your wager making your
punishment too unrealistic there's no
there's what should be the punishment
then well i say reduce a thousand
burpees down to 100 [ __ ] a
chimpanzee's dick
oh god again are you gonna get to give
each of us five hundred dollars
y'all each have you have five hundred
dollars to give up all of us
well i don't have any money right now
because technically you're gonna have to
find that money
well you gotta send us you gotta send us
all in this room a bitcoin
okay one full bitcoin split it up among
this group i'll give you a physical coin
no give you a bit of a call see it has
to make you feel like this
i think the pressure has to make you
feel just enough to where you're like i
don't want to lose this
true all right and there's no way out so
what's the punishment give me a bitcoin
i don't have that many to give out you
buy a bitcoin right now
you don't get to have it if you don't
have the script done it goes to us
that's kind of like if you get it done
it goes back to you and then you guys
give
us a bitcoin no no what do we gotta do
we're just keeping you accountable we're
already motivated with our own shows oh
why do you guys get [ __ ] out of it
well okay why how about because she
would ask this for our house
that's our feet we don't finish it if i
lose weight you pay me don't get it
in the movie i don't want to be in it
yeah but if you guys
we're trying to help we're trying to
finish yeah
there's a good book you could read
called finish really yeah it's pretty
good you're not going to finish the book
by the time i read it the deadline's
going to be up true
yeah i read my first book in like 10
years during the quarantine so that's
safety yeah this is always brought to
you by
people don't read like you know the
average person after high school doesn't
read any books no i literally have not
read a book since like high school
that's
crazy before college the few years
college i read a book a month at least
excuse me it's always none let's make
her feel like [ __ ]
yeah what kind of what kind of uh i read
mad books what brings you
to read why would anybody wanted yeah
why would anyone i mean
there's audio books now i like learning
well you're a filmmaker don't you want
to learn more like
when you're like how do i advance my
skill right and i think that's the thing
you watch movies
yeah yeah pick up a camera and you start
shooting isn't it better if someone with
20 years experience is telling you all
the
things that they figured out but they're
not really telling me that i had the
[ __ ] reading so like if you read
books written by millionaires and
they're all kind of saying a similar
thing you're like [ __ ] if i change my
mindset to be like this
then it starts to match and then you're
my but i'm friends with you guys so i
just copy what you do yeah
okay well that's what millionaires say
they said you become the average i'll be
reading books
hell yeah dude how you think this [ __ ]
was built you don't read a book ew
yes shame me into it please that's what
i need i need to be uh pressured into
something so i can prove
neg me mm-hmm yeah make me into this
[ __ ] i bet you can't read no books
damn okay if you don't finish your
script you have to read a book and write
an essay on it oh
that's pretty very bad back to birth
art history book oh i i was an art major
i
[ __ ] i hated art history that's what
i'm saying [ __ ] it sucks it's one of the
worst kinds
let's [ __ ] dissect this video well
okay i'm down give me okay neg me into
it and also give me a deadline
yeah when is the deadline buy next jk
news monday
you're crazy bart's trying to do some
crazy [ __ ] on you guys
i think that's the only way it works
dude a month even no i don't even know
what [ __ ] story i'm gonna write
write an outline tonight when you're
pressured you are the most creative
yeah that's when i work the best exactly
right it's all it's
in two weeks i think that's fair two
weeks they'll still wait till the friday
before the last day hey but at least
they have something
that's true yeah which you gotta write
uh laura mitzva ipsum or whatever for
[ __ ]
72 pages what's easier for you guys
sticking to a diet for a month or just
fasting for 24 hours
fast fasting exactly so write the script
in 48 hours
like that yeah i already got it it
doesn't work cause i already have [ __ ]
to do after this
i gotta go edit i gotta do it that's
just not important i need a time
management skills i say a month
i'll talk to the media weeks
three weeks take your goal cut it in
half
damn i think by jk news because it makes
it easier for me
yeah so that if they don't have the
script by next cheeky news
and then the next time did he give us a
big one the next time tim comes back on
jk news how about that hey you want to
come next week i'll come back
just give me a bitcoin dude so two weeks
in two weeks guys
yeah you guys all finish the script and
i will bully you
at least it's not cyberbullying a script
in two weeks and all cyberbullying
you're reading it
um and then so we keep each other
accountable we'll keep you guys
accountable
but there's got to be in it for i'm just
kidding i don't care if there's anything
in it for me but i want to watch you
guys sacrifice to you guys
i'm gonna hope that you guys don't come
up with a [ __ ] script because i want
to see you guys do
like a hundred burpees and have a
flashbang right here on jk news
flashbang we have to have orgies on
camera yeah this is that's just
the hot sauce it's [ __ ] hot though
dude it's some jk party [ __ ] dude oh
yeah it's not i never even was on that
what how many pages is the average
script
19 85 85 90 super duper yeah
okay so 85 divided by 14 days that's
only like 40 pages a week there's a lot
more that goes into it yeah
40 divided by seven that's like so i
mean six seven pages a day yeah that's
not that bad
that's like three seconds i can't hang
up on like one page it's like two scenes
real quick though uh quick plug this is
exactly what we do
on my live call it's called tell me to
detail and um everyone that's in it i
make them all
accountable for something and then we'll
have a goal we say it out loud and we'll
tell each other hey who wants to buddy
up with someone
and keep them accountable i make sure
that goals get done within
the group that's dope this is exactly
the kind of [ __ ] that we do
two weeks i like rough drafts that's
that's doable i'm gonna leave the link
in the
description below if you want to be a
part of time in a detail that's [ __ ]
do it be [ __ ] positive
the problem is if it's two weeks after
one week i'm gonna check in on you guys
and you guys didn't write anything
because i have one more week left
well that's fine i mean they could do
whatever they want but here's the thing
though
what is the punishment because i want to
see that yeah yeah
we have to make out with each other you
got a drink
at the same time that's nothing no
that's nothing
you know what's gonna what you know
what's gonna you know what's gonna make
the make this go
like even crazier is that if one of them
don't even finish so now everyone has to
finish
oh one of them [ __ ] you guys all three
of you guys have to [ __ ] do this so
it's a team effort
oh so you have the support that's fair
yeah you have the support of the fans
of each other if you fail pretty good
though oh the
now you know the burden of if you fail
we all fail i hate group projects so
and you have to kiss each other what do
you want to see is kiss
and you have to touch dicks
i want to do something where they will
fail though because it's going to be
funny
that's way funnier it's content guys i
know
all right what was it uh burpees i want
to see you guys finish
me too thank you bart but that's why the
punishment has to be so good
deep enough but not impossible right
blood pact
can i set it up where you guys kind of
fail though no
no we want them to win what's that hot
sauce y'all were talking about flash
bang
okay it's crazy 100 100 burpees every 10
burpee
a drop are you dog what do you think
what do you guys think that's ridiculous
no you got to eat it goes on a thousand
burpees
this is so strong you can't do more than
two drops of flashbang dude all right
for every
flash burpee flashbang will [ __ ] you up
true
well i think i did one on my tongue off
a toothpick and i was
throwing up are you kidding [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah great get the script done oh god a
hundred burpees uh
it's one of those hot 100 burpees in a
flash bank yeah
drop all right one drop one drop one
drop of flashbang
[ __ ] let's just get it done then
where is flashbang yeah we'll order
you can't do it i guess well okay you
guys heard it
from this point on be in their guys's
dms
got two weeks we got two weeks this
must go up immediately a good writing
exercise too is if you just write for
three pages at least like without just
no don't think about it just every
morning
right like for three pages and like just
gets you in the habit of writing and
then you're
you're kind of like jogged i hate it and
if they half-ass this
all three of them are making out
simultaneously on camera
with the flashlight yeah with the
flashlight oh [ __ ] no that's a real
flashbang a silent film
oh that's pretty good that's even harder
zero dialogue and how much description
you have to write
but there's so much camera movement
that's it bob walks over there
bob box back over here bob stares at
girl for five
hours that's that long of a sentence
dude
80 pages yeah no he's saying that's the
whole movie and we'll schedule the table
reads for all of these for a week after
yeah what have we teamed up and wrote
one script no
no we actually i want to do all myself
[ __ ] i want their own [ __ ] group project
autobiography all right [ __ ] it fine
let's do it yeah
we better see a script by two weeks
caught between a kiss in a hot place
tim casey and dean now find themselves
locked into a peer pressure competition
to determine if they have what it takes
to write an 85 page script
in only two weeks but june 12th
approaching fast
will they succeed or will they find
themselves making out with hot sauce
have that popcorn handy and your red
pins ready because you'll find out in
two weeks
on just kidding news
you